[Music]
recently valve and bethesda started to
let sky ramadas charge for their
creations on the Steam Workshop the
whole plans are to blow up in their face
and they stopped the program but not
before inciting a debate over the issue
of paying for mods what I've come to
notice about the debate between Pro paid
mod people and anti paid mod people is
that what everybody seems to want is to
nurture the modding community each side
of the debate seems certain that the
opposing sides plan for mods will crush
the growth of that modding community and
that's a valiant reason to stand up for
your opinions over the years mods have
given us a lot more than simply up
scaled graphics and the option to remove
that pesky mosaic keeping you from
seeing your sims private bits whether
you're for or against the idea of paying
for mods I thought I'd showcase five of
the very best mods ever to be created
most of which eventually went on to be
their own standalone money-making
products
let's start with one of the most
beautiful community driven remakes ever
made black mesa if you're a fan of
half-life i implore you to give black
mesa your time this free mod developed
by crowbar collective has taken 8 years
to develop and has remade a large chunk
of half-life using the Source engine I
personally find the soundtrack to be one
of the best in gaming and the 40 person
dev team did a lovely job of revamping
the environment and gameplay to enhance
what was already one of gaming's
quintessential experiences whether or
not you're into eSports I'm personally a
fan of giving credit where it's due and
the original dirt a mod for Warcraft 3
created an entire genre Defense of the
Ancients was developed using the world
editor from Warcraft 3 rain of chaos in
2008 Gamasutra called erta they quote
most popular and most discussed free
non-supported game mod in the world
while several authors contributed to the
development and evolution of the arena
mod 2 are especially
notable Steve Ginsu fake who eventually
ended up at Riot Games designing League
of Legends and an anonymous dev known as
icefrog
who took the reins of the dota mod from
fake in 2005 and in 2009 was hired by
valve to create the sequel tota to
defense of the ancients created the MOBA
genre and love them or hate them Lowell
and Darla are now two of the most played
games in the world
all thanks to modding in the creativity
Awards category we have a winner and a
runner-up as randomly decided by me as I
was scripting this video you're
arbitrarily decided upon runner-up is
Daisy X air force officer Dean rocket
Hall turned the tactical simulator
armored tomb into a totally different
beast when he decided to add zombies to
it and build Daisy sure the mod is
broken as all get-out as many mods ah
but the multiplayer open-world zombie
apocalypse had a lot of gamers totally
enthralled the world of dayz is
cutthroat and terrifying the zombies are
trying to kill you the players may or
may not be trying to kill you and
sometimes you'll want to kill yourself
just to escape the grim realities on
what happens to people in an apocalyptic
wasteland what trusted integrity are as
dead as most of the inhabitants so then
I guess you're wondering what's more
creative than turning a military shooter
into a zombie apocalypse
well it's turning a shooter into
absolutely nothing and everything that's
what you'll get
with Gary's lon created by Gary Numan in
2004 Garry's Mod is a wonderfully insane
sandbox physics game created in a
modified Source engine in Garry's Mod
you have two things at your disposal a
physics gun for picking up and adjusting
objects and a tool gun for creating
buttons popping props together and
things like that well you can basically
do anything with the game most
multiplayer servers offer original game
modes created within the game by players
so mods created within the mod mod
section if you like these include things
like trouble and terror
town where a group of players have to
work out which one among them is the
traitor trying to kill everyone off and
a bizarre elevator riding simulator
called elevator sauce where each floor
offers increasingly dumb experiences
it's worth noting that garrysmod and
Black Mesa dirt even scratched the
surface of all the great half-life mods
cry of fear natural selection and the
Stanley parable are all honorable
mentions in that category there's
another game that fits within that
half-life mods list but it's just a
little too impressive to be constrained
to an honorable mention and that's
counter-strike this popular team-based
multiplayer half-life mod featured
hostage rescue and bomb defusal missions
with each team equipped with unique
equipment and goals and basically gamers
lapped it up like dota counter-strike
offered up a super-fun multiplayer
experience that featured an emphasis on
teamwork and effective communication
required for victory and as seems to
have become a theme with the company
valve proved they knew a good thing when
they saw it the company snapped up the
mods creators and gave them jobs at
valve they then contributed to the
eventual creation of CS sauce and CS
global Offensive let me know which mod
is your favorite and what you think of
the modding community either in that
comment section down below or you can
find me on Twitter where I'm at chest
MacDonald I'll catch you again next week
[Music]